[Music]
on this Saturday night tridemic impact
surging flu cases along with RSV and
covid-19 cause closures and canceled
surgeries at Children's hospices and
hospitals it's just all unprecedented in
so many ways plastic pollution as Canada
prepares to ban some single-use Plastics
world leaders meet to discuss a global
strategy corruption disruption the
world's largest active volcano threatens
Hawaii's highways plus homegrown hip-hop
the medicine is inside meet the
indigenous high school students behind
this award-winning music video
global national with far and answer
reporting tonight Jeff Semple good
evening and thank you for joining us if
you and your family are canceling
weekend plans due to illness you're not
alone the respiratory virus season is
hitting hard and fast this year
hospitals across the country are
struggling to cope with a combination of
illnesses including the seasonal flu
Alberta is one of the hardest hit
regions in the country right now
influenza cases there are spiking early
and hitting levels not seen since 2009
that's the year the new H1N1 virus first
emerged as Marty blunt reports that's
forcing medical workers to make some
difficult decisions this weekend
thank you
people are out and about stores open for
business and few masks in sight life is
seemingly the closest to normal it's
been in nearly three years but this
could be the Calm before another storm
according to a new warning from the
World Health Organization gaps in
surveillance testing sequencing and
vaccination are continuing to create the
perfect conditions for a new variant of
consent to emerge that could cause
significant mortality with unrestrained
transmission new variants can and will
emerge the warning comes as hospitals
grapple with a so-called triedemic
seeing an influx of kova 19 RSV and flu
cases at once
South of the Border the CDC is sounding
the alarm over skyrocketing flu cases
across the country with nearly 20 000
people being admitted to hospital last
week almost double the number seen the
week before here in Canada many
hospitals are already at a Tipping Point
dealing with overwhelmed emergency
departments due to respiratory issues in
Alberta Health officials have been
forced to temporarily pause respite
services at Calgary's rotary Flames
house in order to redeploy staff to the
Children's Hospital it's quite sad that
it has come to this I think they're
trying to minimize the impact on the
rest of the patients as much as they can
but it's now starting to have impact on
patient care in St John's the Children's
Hospital is the latest to cancel
surgeries and delay appointments due to
a surge in patients and officials at
Winnipeg's HSC children's are warning
they could be in trouble if we don't
slow the spread our season is going to
last longer it's going to Peak higher
um and it's peaky and we're getting
there fast epidemiologists say these are
Extraordinary Measures it's just all
unprecedented in so many ways and every
week There's a new unprecedented
development in the realm of clinical
care and in population Health Dio nandin
as it is surprising that these are the
drastic measures we have to take given
that there were signals months earlier
that we would be in this level of Crisis
he also says with hospitals strained and
pandemic restrictions disappearing
curtailing this triedemic could once
again boil down to individual choices
Jeff Marnie blunt in Ottawa thanks
Marnie
China is relaxing some of its strict
covid-19 measures this weekend after
public frustration with its pandemic
policies boiled over into unrest in
recent weeks
long lines for covid-19 tests were seen
across Beijing today after China shut
down many of its testing booths Beijing
has now removed negative test results as
a condition to enter grocery stores the
same goes for Subways in cities such as
Shenzhen China is set to announce
further testing reductions in
requirements despite daily case totals
at near record highs and some experts
worry what the relaxing restrictions in
such a large population could mean for
the creation of covid-19 variants
for example if you had a huge population
that had not been exposed previously and
the virus takes off in that population
it's no longer immunescape that's
conferring an advantage on on different
versions of the virus it's more like
transmissibility you know ability to
infect on a larger scale so if it were
to tear through China for example where
they don't have this background of past
infection and they don't have the same
vaccination the same I would say
effectiveness of vaccination and in any
case the vaccines generally don't stop
transmission they stop severe illness
then you might get a really different
direction of evolution from what we've
seen in Western countries where there
has been this background of a lot of
infection
turning to other news now and a major
change is coming soon to Canada's
assisted dying laws and it's already
causing division among medical experts
starting in March it will be legal for
people with mental health issues to
receive medical assistance in dying but
some of Canada's top psychiatrists and
families of patients are warning that
will set a dangerous precedent Global
Nationals new Ottawa reporter tariya
isri has more
psychiatrists are trained to deal with
people in crisis but some are now having
their own crisis of confidence when it
comes to medically assisted dying our
role as therapists psychiatrists is in
suicide prevention and so to ask us to
then facilitate suicide is very
dissonant the laws around medical
assistance in dying or made are set to
expand including Canadians with mental
illness
but medical experts across the country
warn Canada's Health Care system is not
ready and we already know there's not
really clear consensus on a definition
of for example what it means for someone
to have a mental illness that is
incurable or irremediable so we already
know there's this risk of inconsistent
application made when made became legal
seven years ago only patients with a
terminal illness were eligible in 2019 a
Quebec judge ruled this restriction was
unconstitutional so Parliament amended
the bill in my view mental illness is no
different than any other medical illness
I believe that doctors are quite capable
of assessing people with psychiatric
illness and coming to the same
conclusions that they have for people
who have a you know cancer or lung
disease or a neurological disorders but
families of patients worry there are not
enough protections we are so angry and
insulted at how they just all turn their
heads nutrition Vehicles told a
parliamentary committee that her brother
Alan was suicidal when he checked into
the Chilliwack Hospital July 16 2019.
ten days later he died with medical
assistance how did our government even
be looking at expanding made laws
there are currently no laws protecting
the vulnerable or their families from
made we understand that making sure
we're respecting people's rights and
their choices at the same time as we
protect the most vulnerable
is a very important but challenging
balance to establish psychiatrists fear
that balance will be even harder to
strike with the health care System under
immense pressure telling my patients
that you will make it easier for them to
die has enraged me they will die because
of lack of services they will die
because psychiatrists will now have
legal permission to give up the
Parliamentary committee
to legislation we will have some of the
most lenient assisted dying laws in the
world Korea isri Global News
later this month Canada will begin the
process of banning some single-use
Plastics and this week global leaders
met to negotiate a plan to specifically
Target plastic pollution across the
planet but their task is daunting
Plastics can be found in almost every
aspect of our lives and consumption
continues to grow despite the known
threats to our environment and our
health Redmond Shannon reports
even in the remote and seemingly
pristine landscape of Antarctica
researchers have found microplastics in
the water and ice the microplastic that
we found during this study were mostly
microfibers and these fibers come from
all forms of textiles another new study
in the North Atlantic shows a huge mix
of Plastics in some areas of the ocean
all coming from different parts of the
world we also find paint fragments we
find
Tire dust marine life ingests these
broken down Plastics and they make their
way into our food chain it reinforces
this message of there being no Silver
Bullet solution to tackle the Plastics
issue on the mouth of the La Plata River
in Uruguay the next step toward a
solution has begun government
delegations meeting for the first of six
Summits to hammer out a legally binding
treaty by 2024. some of the measures
being considered include a cap or even a
ban on new plastic production setting up
a circular economy for reusing plastic
items restricting the export of plastic
waste and removing harmful chemicals
from plastics it's estimated there are
10 000 types of chemical additives in
different Plastics over two and a half
thousand are known to be toxic and
harmful both to humans and other
organisms many scientists say a Plastics
treaty must hold countries to account
unlike the voluntary model of the Paris
agreement on climate change we need a
transformative shift a current uh use
and predicted increase in plastic uses
is is going to increase and um so we
need strict binding agreements such as
the Plastics treaty Canada is part of a
so-called High ambition Coalition
pushing for illegally binding treaty
notably the group doesn't include major
plastic producers like the U.S and China
meanwhile Canada's ban on some
single-use plastic items like Cutlery
bags and straws begins its three-year
rollout on December 20th Redmond Shannon
Global News London
and a little later in the newscast we'll
look at the growing costs of climate
change and how some Canadian communities
are trying to adapt
to Hawaii now where thousands of people
on the big island are enjoying a view
that's both beautiful and dangerous the
eruption of the world's largest active
volcano the lava flowing from Mauna Loa
is now making Transportation officials
nervous as Jennifer Johnson reports the
volcano is threatening the islands Main
Highway
corruption a monologue
first in 38 years is majestic and
spiritual for many Hawaiians I saw the
1984 Mauna Loa and I followed the Pu o
eruptions it's like the goddess returns
for now that's true homes and
neighborhoods have been spared but the
volcano's slow-moving lava is edging
closer to the big Island's main
transportation route the DKI highway
it's very high probability that this
lava flow if it continues will
definitely reach the road so we're
looking at about two days out Hawaii
County's Civil Defense Agency says if
lava flows onto the highway residents
tourists and delivery trucks will be
forced to travel along Coastal roads
taking hours longer to get to the
Island's main cities and the agency
predicts it will take the federal
government months to get the highway
passable again another eruption could
threaten neighborhoods something
thousands of residents fear about 700
homes were destroyed in the 2018 Kilauea
eruption it was a rough time you know it
was uh as spectacular and as beautiful
as as you know these are options can be
it's it's very difficult when it's uh
impacts communities and families for now
all that scientists and government
officials can do is watch and wait
schools and businesses near the volcano
remain open cars are still moving on the
DKI highway but the lava's path a once
in a lifetime spectacle that has
attracted thousands of tourists is
threatening to change all that
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
unprecedented provincial Powers coming
up the Alberta premiers proposed changes
to her controversial sovereignty Act
plus sending reinforcements why these
Canadian soldiers are heading to Europe
[Music]
more than 100 Canadian Armed Forces
Personnel left Alberta for Latvia today
joining a multinational battle group
that's part of NATO's operation
reassurance the aim of the mission is to
relieve existing Canadian troops there
from Manitoba and reinforce the treaty's
collective defenses in the face of
growing Russian aggression the Canadian
contingent will work directly with the
Latvian Army for the next six months to
train and strengthen Europe's Eastern
flank Alberta Premier Danielle Smith
fulfilled a campaign promise this week
to introduce the Alberta sovereignty act
Smith says the ACT is designed to
protect Alberta's interests allowing the
provincial government to ignore federal
laws that it deems harmful to Alberta it
would also allow Smith and her cabinet
to rewrite bills unilaterally sparking
criticism from some calling the ACT
unconstitutional and undemocratic this
week on the west block our Mercedes
Stevensons takes a closer look at the
move in an interview with the premier
Jeff Premier Danielle Smith says the ACT
isn't designed to override the Alberta
legislature nor meant as a power grab
both criticisms leveled at her after the
bill was tabled Smith says she
recognizes the concerns people have
about how the bill has been written and
is open to changing it I understand
there's a problem with one of the
Clauses people have raised some concerns
about us we're taking a look at that if
we need to tidy a few things up then
we'll do that because the intention has
always been to make sure that the that
anything that we do any action that we
take has been fully debated by those who
are represented to uh to to represent
the interests of the people of Alberta
the potential mid-course change raises
questions about why the Smith government
table the bill with such an
unprecedented power in the first place
the bill also empowers Alberta to ignore
Federal legislation it deems harmful to
Alberta's interests I asked the premier
if she has a specific Target in mind for
when she might use it first and she
identified two possibilities the oil and
gas sector emissions cap or the
fertilizer cap for Farmers being
introduced by Ottawa one thing is clear
the bill is aimed at putting the onus
and Target on Justin Trudeau and the
liberal government in Ottawa whether
that's through the letter or Spirit of
the sovereignty act I think we've tried
to be a constructive partner in
Confederation and it hasn't worked so
we've got to try something different and
that's what this sovereignty Act is all
about Smith says she believes the bill
is already doing its critical job
sending a message to Ottawa and the
premier will tell us what evidence she
thinks she has that the federal
government may be softening on some
positions we'll talk about all that and
whether the bill is a necessary strategy
or political theater plus we'll sit down
with the former Ukrainian president
Petro poroshenko on why he thinks the
International Community needs to abandon
hopes of diplomacy with Russia to end
the war in Ukraine Jeff thanks Mercedes
and you can watch the full interview
with the Alberta Premier tomorrow
morning on the west block right here on
global
[Music]
still ahead how Canadian communities are
adapting to climate change
[Music]
[Music]
some spectacular views high above Earth
today as two NASA astronauts geared up
for a seven hour spacewalk on the
International Space Station among the
meticulous maintenance they're
performing in zero gravity the main goal
is to install a brand new solar array
that's expected to significantly boost
the station's electric power which will
be a big help to operations and research
on board
back down here on Earth the effects of
climate change are being felt with
greater frequency and severity and
there's growing recognition that the
world needs to do more to prepare for
extreme weather events kamiar razavi
reports on how some Canadian communities
are adapting
this is what the city of Peterborough
two hours East of Toronto looked like in
July 2004.
150 millimeters of rain falling on the
community in one hour it was obviously
one of the worst floods that we've seen
in the city since then the city has been
working hard to upgrade its
infrastructure and to adapt to extreme
weather a task that's become more urgent
and immediate across the country as
climate change fuels extreme weather
now in BC's Fraser Valley Farms even the
highway completely submerged last year
in devastating flooding this is about
helping the country adapt to the new
reality of climate change last week Bill
Blair Canada's emergency preparedness
Minister announced 1.6 billion in new
spending for adaptation measures in
Peterborough that work had long begun
before the federal announcement they're
working with a mapping company called
ecopia AI to help planners make
predictions of where the water will go
in case of flooding and every single
sewer storm drain every single catch
Basin water course
everything in the city it's a high-tech
response to an age-old problem
emphasizing what climate adaptation
experts say is the need to be prepared
ahead of time
it's very clear at this point
more municipalities are taking this
seriously not just because they have to
but because they want to in the future
we're going to be looking at
municipalities who
um are recognized for being climate
resilient and their property values are
going to go up because people are going
to want to live there adapting to the
reality of a dangerously warming planet
Cameo rosavi Global News
[Music]
up next High School Musical the students
and the story behind this new music
video
[Music]
welcome back a group of indigenous
students in chateauge Quebec are making
waves with a new music video their
original song premiered this week at
their Howard s Billings high school as
Gloria Enriquez explains the video hopes
to inspire others about the importance
of reconnecting with their indigenous
roots
[Music]
the video could belong in any
International Music Channel and the
artist signed to any famous record label
but this talented Bunch isn't too far to
reach they can be easily found hanging
out in the halls of the Howard and
spillings high school it's not like me
to
be so out there not very outgoing so
being able to um like be out there was
pretty awesome with the four of you
please come up to the stage
so now local Stars responded to a call
out at school for indigenous students to
create a music video the project is part
of the new Janan program for indigenous
youth to share their voices and talents
they show that we're here you know
[Music]
for five days
skin the blue eyes my life's like a new
tide the medicine is inside I could
never lose Pride from the Judgment they
can experience for the way they
looked by the things I do to the
Prejudice and false preconceptions some
have about people living in a reserve
this like proves people that like that
stigma like isn't true at all and that
like native people like can accomplish
like big things the video premiered in
front of their whole school we were all
super nervous you know just trying to
cover each other because it was just
like super nerve-wracking you know but
they conquered their fears
out and prove that together
no need to worry about it now I feel so
free cause I got me and I got you they
can overcome anything and most
importantly they have the power to write
their own story
[Music]
Enriquez Global News chatea Gay
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight
your Canada is the lights at LaFarge
Lake display in Coquitlam British
Columbia we love seeing your Canada so
please send us your holiday themed
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here again tomorrow have a great night